jean paul chang bonjour je vous remercie
d'avoir accepté notre invitation pour
parler de ce sommet pour la démocratie
de jo leinen mais avant un mot sur ce
boycott de des états unis notamment mais
pas seulement du canada du royaume uni
ce boycott diplomatique
aucun représentant officiel aux jeux
d'hiver ne sera envoyé en raison je cite
des violations des droits de l'homme la
chine a répondu sans s'en fiche
comment est-ce que ce boycott
diplomatique là qui est en train de se
jouer et est perçue en chine
sa mission comme les chinois de le voir
d'abord les cinq pays c'est ce qu'on
appelle le fife as avait des cinq pays
donc fonder une communauté
de
l'information qui sont les clients aux
accents par contre la chine regarde
d'après effectivement quelle
d'indécision que les pays européens vont
pour adopter est ce que l'europe va suis
finalement il n'y a qu'un là dessus même
si dans les faits que disney déjà le
porte-parole du mr étrangères chinois
soit n'aura pas de complot mais comment
d'impact du tout sur l'organisation des
au nom des jeux sont persuadés que toute
façon avec l'arrivée des appelés du
monde entier des jeux seront bien suivi
et souvent un succès
mais ils sont arrivés à la conclusion
toute façon s'ils visent occidentaux
croient que la chine en est encore la
face n'a pas peur de perdre la face et
bien en fait ce temps est bien révolu
en tout cas il préfère que les choses
continuent dans la réalité
tranquillement plutôt que de suivre à
tout moment des postures idéologiques
alors un boycott
juste avant ce fameux sommet pour la
démocratie voulue par par joe biden à
sommet auquel les grandes puissances
comme la russie ou encore la chine ne
sont pas conviés certains y voient
d'ailleurs une offensive géopolitique
contre la chine c'est comme ça que la
chine leur soyez mans
puis s'y attendait depuis l'annnonce des
eaux peu de ce sommet en février par un
tueur bayonne la chine s'attendent à un
certain à voir venir mots les coûts et
du bois dans l'invitation des
représentants de taiwan et d'un
dissident
chinois de hong kong une provocation
supplémentaire vis-à-vis est d'abord que
la chine et puis là dessus là aussi ils
se sont préparés et sont difficilement
que si une bonne opportunité
d'afficher haut et fort finalement la
proposition donc le monde en chinois à
huy le temps depuis février de préparer
un livre blanc sur la démocratie en
chine donc qu'ils ont publié il ya
quelques jours parce que la chine se
considère elle-même comme une démocratie
et considère que la démocratie n'a pas
un modèle unique qu'on pourrait imposer
partout dans le monde comme celle à qui
on essaie de le faire quelquefois par la
force donc ils ont publié un livre blanc
et d'autres
justement sur cette notion de la
démocratie
elle est perçue différemment aux états
unis et en chine qu'est-ce qu'est ce
qu'on dise des chinois
en tout cas
la position officielle du parti
communiste chinois c'est que la
démocratie existe en chine et qu'il
existe même des processus d'élection à
la base dans la vaste campagne chinoise
à des échelons de base des villages
chinois et que finalement chaque pays
progresse vers la démocratie a sa propre
façon ils ont publié un deuxième
document ils ont fait une moue en cas en
publicité les cieux en papier d'un think
tank chinois qui est plutôt spécialisé
dans les questions financières
difficiles c'est dix questions sur la
démocratie américaine en même temps ils
se disent bon bah voilà
la démocratie à l'occidentale avec la
domination de l'argent la manipulation
de l'opinion par les médias
et démocratie les conséquences que cela
même ses sens aussi démocratie au niveau
international bref en tout cas les
chiens sont préparés à contrer un peu ce
sommet de washington avec donc une
petite série d'actions de
relations publiques et de publications
documents pour affirmer que la chine
n'est pas du tout gênée par ce sommet
même si elle est très irrité par la
volonté de provocation des médias voient
invités taiwan et un copain dissidente
de rencontre j'ai recherché par la
police de hong kong alors il ya de
nombreux alliés et partenaires des états
unis qui ont désormais davantage de
liens commerciaux avec la chine qu'avec
les états unis est-ce qu'il ya aussi
derrière ce sommet pour la démocratie
une volonté de contrer l'économie
chinoise
écoutez contre les communistes chinoises
écoutez c'est ce sera probablement sur
des thèmes de
sanctions économiques que ces pays où on
prendre à cause des pelles ou tel
problème qu'il met en avant sur les
transports glaxo démocratique cela étant
je suis simplement empêché finalement
les les grands courants réel puisque on
a vu que sur les onze premiers mois de
l'année le commerce chinois né à cannes
un sommet historique donc pensant l'aï
les affaires continuent
maintenant que ce soit un moyen pour les
américains de faire un retour au premier
plan la mairie kaïs pack n'est ce pas
que me disent les démocrates avec
monsieur baden
c'est une tentative de retrouver une
sorte de leadership américain leadership
mondial et cette fois ci sur des thèmes
de l'idéologique en tout cas sur thème
des valeurs donc là dessus ainsi dès les
choses sont claires d'un côté comme de
l'autre série a n'est qu'un ils veulent
reprendre lamas et autres
cellules
une alliance
redynamiser l'alliance des pays hôtes
cmc a nié et
les chinois bombe par contre ne pense
pas que en tout cas jusque jusque
maintenant que cela
impliquera finalement l'arrêt des
échanges commerciaux qui sont très très
importante entre la chine le contrat
chinois du monde merci beaucoup
jean-paul chang pour votre éclairage ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes
spécialiste de l'économie chinoise pro
fondateur de la lettre de chine